[Music]
every day uh my grandma would tell me
your mom's not coming back she doesn't
love you and when my dad would come home
at dinner time I had to say that my mom
didn't love me and she wasn't coming
back and I refused to say it so I had to
go to bed without dinner and I would get
a spanking we did this for about 2
years
uh not obviously not a good alliance to
have she never did come
back so I don't know what was worse like
the the screaming for her in my head or
the silence when I forgot she existed
cuz Silence has a sound
too and how old are you now uh 23 23 and
you got a black eye yeah how'd you get
the black eyy um a date um I asked him
to go get some more crack and he just
took off on me um I'm a clone so people
control me um being sober and being in
recovery are two different things I just
want to put that out there and I'm in
recovery I'm I'm here to make
action and do the things that I can do
to stay sober for the rest of my
life when I when I decided to go ahead
and do
it it was more of a statement that I was
making and that I needed to make at the
time cuz I was trying to establish
myself but my dad stopped raising me
when I was um I was able to tell tell on
on him you know for molesting me and um
raping and molesting me from the age of
uh 9 to 15 and I was finally able to
tell somebody I I end up getting
pregnant so oh with your dad yeah
wow so I have a child by my father
yeah I'm like miserable all the time
and I'm trying to get
myself to go back to rehab cuz my kids
are getting older
now the other two are 13 and
15 but I stand behind everything that I
tell you I'm not a buster I'm not a m
I'm not a [__] I'm a soldier that
stands on the front line of this [__]
and I like I said again ain't afraid of
nothing you can send your best buddy at
me he can be King Kong son I'll take his
ass home and if he whoop me at least I
know I took him
home I've been living
life the maximum uh bum status just not
that I don't give a
[__]
but I'm absolutely not wasting any
effort on any
anything until it's
time in Memphis Tennessee old I was like
I was one year old I was One S when he
died right and my mother she died when I
was like I was in the uh fifth grade I
was going on I've been in the hospital
and my cancers getting
worse what kind of cancer do you have
again stomach cancer and brain cancer I
got a tumor in my brain and four in my
stomach it gave me less than 6 months
now it's been about four so I got four
months
left so I'm on one side of the street
and I hear a voice yelling at me you're
in my territory get out of here and I
look across the street and I see a guy a
little shorter than me so he starts
walking towards me I walk towards him he
says to me this is my
territory you need to get out of here
I'll bust your head and I look up at the
street sign and I said I don't see your
name what's your name and he says Splat
TR I said I don't see your name in that
street sign and I'll be back here
tomorrow he said well when I come back
tomorrow I'm busting your head I said
I'll be
back I made my own
choices it's hard being out here they
going in people's tent they molested 3
weeks
ago they molested a 16-year-old little
boy finally somebody called by the time
the police got there when they bought
that baby out of that ttin he was Bloody
from head to toe they looked at that
camera men so many guys went in that
tent and molested this little boy and
they call theyself gang members in
stuff how' you get around you you guys
had cars back then oh we had a horse uh
we had a horse and
Slayer and uh I travel through the
mountain from boring Detroit down mider
for through the
mountain I just want to [__] [__] up you
know I just want to get drunk and high
and just [__] [__]
up
first time I went to jail was a
robbery was gang bang at the
time um young 15 years old R
Jewish on the same night
got a nice little of
money back then $7,000 was a lot of
money I know um not me man I'm more of a
of a lover and a fighter but I I like to
love man you know some people just some
females don't know what that really
means like or they did but then got so
abused that it's like now it's like it's
hard for them to trust and to love I'm
hoping that I can switch all that around
you know so I don't
know because I don't I'm not one who
makes a ho do
anything she does it because she wants
to you know I've had several plenty of
hoes C me chosen I want to I want I want
I want to be down with you you know
[__] it's a choosing feet that come
with me you talking to me [__] I don't
see no bread in my hand I get over that
recruiting officer and told him I was 17
years old how old were you actually he
said huh how old were you actually 13 I
was 13 but but you have to be 17 before
you get in the United States Army and uh
that recruiting offic said Mr Wilson you
look very very young he said I don't
believe you are 17 years old you know I
said yes my mother do you stay in an RV
uh no I actually uh uh um I uh I hold
down a lodge u a dark Lodge I like to
call it it's a sort of
a um Masonic uh what do you call
it unorthodox Masonic Innovation uh I
keep an outside Lodge a Red Lodge I
believe it's supporting The
Establishment and keep it an eye on
things from the outside you know what I
mean and and making sure that you know
like a you know I believe in our economy
and in our establishment is this a tent
that you're in uh yeah I stay in a tent
or outside you know it's usually my and
I was going to jail for like robbery
grand theft and it was like I was going
to spend my whole life like in jail if I
kept going down that like type of path
so I decided easier path with easier
money and that's
it they'll pop up in any vacant lot you
see sure I'm sure I've seen any other
that's a marshmallow so basically you
just got a bag of lawn
clippings all right and you know you
somehow I broke myself free before they
could stab
me there's these concrete steps that go
from the front door to this gravel
driveway and I jumped and they were
running right behind me and they jumped
as
well and the guy dropped the knife yes I
was married four kids two boys two girls
which I haven't unfortunately I haven't
been in touched with in some years now
they're grown all of them are grown I
got uh three kids by my wife and one kid
out of marriage you have running water
yeah you do yeah I run it out the
holler got a water fil it comes off of
so you tap into that yeah yeah I can't
drank it but I can bath in it and wash
my clothes and dishes right my white
meal friends I kind of like them more I
think in the long run I think I might
end up marrying a white man I'm not sure
but I think that's what might happen
find a sugar daddy and you're all yeah
pretty
much I'd actually bit one of these
pedophiles on the side of the face while
I was getting molested once and um I
think my punishment for that is my dad
um took one of these audio recordings of
me getting raped and he sat me down and
he had me listen to them when I was just
four or five years old and you know I
grew up hunting and stuff it sounded
like someone was killing a rabbit over
this audio recording just just gurgling
screaming and I remember my dad looking
at me and laughing and I brought him the
recording and I said it on his desk you
know I I was just a scared kid I don't
know what was going on he looked at me
and he kind of laughed and he says you
don't like listening to that do
you man the politicians by [__] you see
you see how how they bought the [__] up
with trumping them over there in Florida
I mean wherever they got the they got
the lady in prison right now because the
other dude he died or something in
prison he got killed or something right
there yeah because every it's hey
everybody name is in the black book so
they don't want that black book coming
out you know what I'm saying a
[__] a [__] like me
would have had that black book a
[__] would have been dropping
boxes of money off that behind
uh my mom I grew up with my mom very
strong woman uh middle I was a middle
child um she
uh my older brother was the Golden Boy
and my younger son was autistic so I
bore the brunt of everything her mom did
to her and uh she was an alcoholic as
well and she would
um she would beat me
and
um she would uh she'd sexually abuse
me few years after I got into crystal
meth and um yeah alcohol alcohol is my
biggest problem is alcohol number one
it's been my biggest downfall for my
life it's hard man because you know I've
been doing jail prison all my life man
you mean and my dad did it my Grandpa
did it mean my dad's still in prison
right now he's 60 something years old
he's still in prison you know and uh my
uncle something like that I look at them
I'm like [__] I don't want to be 5 55
years old still going into violations
you mean I'm 43 and I can't do it more
I'm go in there now and I'm ready like I
can't do this [__] these people get on
my nerves I can't I don't you know
there's going to be a boy
mhm so what happened there the
miscarriage is my baby was already so
big they had to
um cut my baby up inside me and pull him
out
unfortunately when they cut him out um
they accidentally cut a little bit of my
uterus so I can never have kid skin and
that broke my
heart so where do you see your life
going from here you're 16 I'm probably
going to be
dead how would you die most likely you
think what's what's the most dangerous
most likely way that you would
die my hood just the gang violence and
the guns and all that either my hood or
my
pimp you have a pimp something like
that the reason to be mad at the
world Excuse excuse to be mad the world
and everything cuz this right here but I
don't I can give up I'm not giving
up I can't give
up but won't let me I'm not a violent
person but I had to defend myself it was
a dude that got obsessed with me and
stuff and he kept attacking me and the
the police and stuff wouldn't do nothing
about it because you know who I was and
who he was his mom was an attorney so
and I was just a working woman on the
streets doing drugs so I didn't mean
nothing I went to jail my first time you
did yeah dead ass serious it was a cop
he was undercover a while UNS
supposed came natural you know I learned
at a young
age that
uh when you sex a ho you and they
world but when you get in their mind
they in your
world feel
me yeah when you get in their mind they
in your world but if you sex
them you're in they world if you have
sex with them then you and they were
yeah so it's all about control all all
about control you know not with just
this head but with the other head
too molestation go on till I was 14 from
as young as I can remember Jesus so I
did you say anything did I didn't say
anything until I was
23 and when I it was already too late
but I got shot the hell up I got shot
all in my back and um in my back arm
right here bullet you see Bullet Hole
elbow elbow right here I got I've been
shot nine times and uh and uh and one uh
couple in the leg but um anyway peaches
that was my little heart though at the
time but I was married but so I had her
and my first wife Anita
uh uh that's start anyway
anyway yeah where'd you go to school
Manhattan Princeton for
piano Yale for
running Hunter for Science and I saw
Einstein and I was reading a book and it
took me a long time to get a brain that
would stay captive I was in love with
Indian lore that's all I had I had been
a young girl and I was
very uh petite in the muscle area that
gets stretched
so I didn't know it but they signed me
up for Olympic
Training so I get to
prison and
uh I'm one of those kids that that wants
to like wants to participate you know I
believe I believe
inas in
our in in our in our the thing we have
established in prison right uh our
Southern Hispanics and uh
so you know I start doing I start you
know doing stuff in prison um little
stabbings here little stabbings
there I'm just like my dad rest in peace
he knows it and I apologize before he
died we talked it out he understood why
I did
that never was really
interested in anything that was
successful ever you know I always had an
interest and it always looked good to me
but I think
somehow there was something on the
inside of me that felt that maybe I
didn't deserve success you know so I've
always self- sabotaged always my whole
entire life including
now um excuse me I have to take a shot
like I'm so sorry alcoholism is very
ugly but it's
real I was full Flav with business back
then we had zip guns 22s 25s I'm pretty
two years old
wow all the D is I go with dead or got
life but I was the one that was voted to
get
life cuz I was
wild and you have sex with the girls for
surely I have sex with the girls who
else I'm going to have sex with I'm not
going to go trick my dick out with a
[__] or a square ho that ain't doing
nothing for me if I'm having sex with
any girl it's going to be the girl
that's in my stable that's in my life
that's making sure daddy got everything
well when I was nine my dad was in
prison and I he told my grandma to let
me use his phone for my birthday so um I
was going through his pictures and I
found a video and it was him raping me
when I was four
and then when he got out I confronted
him about it and it started happening
again
so in prison probably 40 I'm 53 so
probably 40 40 years out of those 53 I
spent in prison oh
wow I'd be out I mean I'd be out for
about a week or so and I wind up you
know doing something you know doing
somebody a favor putting in work and go
right back you it really didn't matter
to me back then you
know my mom was mentally [__] she
got hit by a truck on her fifth birthday
in the jam was R so she had a mind like
a kid you know so but I don't know why
or understand why she beat me all the
time and not them and I don't know if
it's a trip I guess cuz I look like my
father I guess I don't know yeah and U I
got taken away I was like it was whole
another story so the sex addiction
bloomed when I was sober because it was
hidden and it was with random people and
then bloomed again when I was on drugs
because it wasn't hidden and it was with
random people and now that I'm a
totaltime fentanyl user um I am asexual
and have no sex at all so uh it's an odd
place to be in I never thought I'm going
to be racist when I started I thought my
life is going to be over in very quickly
you don't think the preaches dick gets
hard when sister Robins walks by with
her fat ass in that tight shirt he
thinking the same thing you thinking
when you look at her with that fat ass
in that tight skirt he not thinking
about how Pious she is or how good of a
parishioner she is or how holy she is he
thinking about what he could do with her
if he had her alone in the room
naked cuz he's a man it's our natural
it's our natural instinct to do that
it's it's our basic human need to
gratify
ourselves Memphis a [__] man you
know what I'm saying like it's e to get
at out here you know what I'm saying so
one thing I had a natural inclination to
was like I caught on quick you feel me
like I was observed I ask a lot of
question what that for why you [__] the
gun like that why you load the bullet
like that why you cut it like that when
you put heat on it what why you put
bacon soda with like I always ask a
thousand questions you know what I'm
saying to the point where I have to [__]
up sometime you know what I'm saying you
can't be in the cop asking question man
you know I'm saying you around ganger
killer pimp Rob murderers you carry G
yeah always always where she it's
close is such thing now is loyalty over
love I rather you be loyal to me than
just come the screen you love me cuz
long as you loyal to me you going to do
all the things that love makes you do
you see what I'm saying so loyalty is
the a word I use not love I am I met my
mother uh when I was 15 in the
penitentary for
murder um and I stayed with the original
Foster family from 6 months until I was
13 um I was basically their
slave um my foster brother sexually
molested me a few blocks it's not no
it's like a huge part of the city yeah
every and the cops you know like they
control it they're the ones who are
letting the [__] in they're the ones who
control everything and they act like you
know spread out for miles in every
direction yeah and I mean like you're
going to sit here and tell me that
you're doing everything you can for this
city when you're the ones making the bus
you're the ones making it possible for
these things to be on the street you're
the ones letting these people go you're
the ones taking them
in I told my girl there something in me
man I can't help it please forgive me if
you think that I'm a cheater and now
it's just I can't help it
I love [__] I like the ass you know
what I'm saying and I tear it up you
have a hard time being a one woman
man yes
yes it's hard time they like I don't
feel in love that quick but this what
she got me I love getting I love getting
high I do I love it it helps me bury my
feelings it helps me it helps me none of
my feelings I don't like feeling and you
can't have feelings and emotions on the
streets anyways feelings emotions cuz
you [__] up and killed so Amber your
what your childhood how would you
describe it how would you describe your
childhood
um my childhood it was okay it was good
my parents was good Christian
people so growing up all the way until
23 it was pretty good and then what
happened at
23 uh I started started smoking and
doing drugs
okay on comfortable weirdness um and
then he he raped me um at the church I
remember parts of
it um and I remember
him um sorry dropping
me back at my house and um me going up
to my bathroom and just undressing and
looking at myself and just seeing
bruises and
I had no one to talk to I didn't tell
anyone um I couldn't even tell my
parents or my
siblings and I had no friends um to tell
so I started using pills I got to the
point to where I had a problem with with
authority you know what I mean I had a
record like this
thick uh being kicked out of schools and
always getting into fights
you know I
figured if my own mom didn't love me
enough to you know to to to to have a
normal life and have a childhood you
know I didn't want to hear what anybody
else had to say you know I like I was
when I was 5 years old I was molested
when I was five you were at a family
reunion
so that plays a part too you know cuz it
was like a family member and it was like
I didn't understand at that age you know
what was going on but when As I Grew
Older it was like who like that's what
you were doing and then and then that
person has kids now so it's like how
could you you
know but that plays a big part
too my brother at the same time but was
my best friend uh I don't talk to no
mother my of my family so my brother was
there for we're there for each other um
he lost his
mind someone smoked him out was a PCP
and he lost his mind right so my mom
gave up on him he was in a psych Bo for
two years years he he he didn't know who
was who you know what I'm saying
um and pretty much I I threw everything
down the drain from for that my mom's
death and my brother I couldn't take it
so I started went back to my gang and
doing things that I thought I knew would
make me feel better which were drugs and
all that you know what I'm
saying and
um since then I've pretty much lost
everything what aspect of all this life
gets you down the most the fact that all
three of my children are not with me
anymore like those were my Shadows I
couldn't even go to the bathroom without
them so to look back and not hear mom at
least a million times in one sentence it
really tears me up because like they are
my everything you know even in junior
high in high school I sold crack cocaine
it went from marijuana to crack the
heroin and then when I found found fany
I mastered the game because I did it
when I was young I just used all my
elements from then until now and I just
applied all my you know all my rules to
the same thing and it it worked out just
like that but eventually you're going to
get you can't get away with it all good
this comes to an end everyone gets
caught right everyone nobody gets away
drugs a part of your life uh marijuana
is mainly I like XX um I have tried the
Crystal but you don't know when people
be putting fit and all up in that stuff
and giving it to you I I don't trust
that stuff no more just uh just Xanax
and marijuana yeah and some alcohol what
what does Xanax do for you Xanax call me
down yeah but Xanax and alcohol is
dangerous right yeah but it calms me
down cuz that's all I've been having is
uppers I didn't I didn't know anything
about ski Road and I was like alone but
I fell in with the wrong
Crow and I was
manipulated
and
G basically just sucking dick for for
hips and stuff like that and I wasn't
making no money at it but I just wanted
to
smoke and you're pregnant now huh you're
pregnant
now um no no you're not pregnant
probably like bloated or
something yeah
yeah so you don't think you're pregnant
I no I think just bloed
so
yeah is is your attitude that
uh regardless of what kind of
relationship it is you're all still
you're still paying for it I'm still
paying for it I hear that a lot still
paying for
it but you know man I'll tell you
this I'm tired of it and I really am
because it's so so much drama and so
much trickeration and so much
[__] that it just put you in a
situation
where aren't you tired of being sick and
tired yeah
yeah I'm
tired he paid me and when he was done I
just felt something weird so when I
looked at him he had a knife to my
throat give me back the money [__] and
I was like oh hell no after everything I
went through he wants his money back
it's not going to work out so I grabbed
the knife and I pulled it down and I
remember him hitting me which look I
don't feel nothing you know so I'm like
try to again and his eyes were like oh
hell go you got the wrong
[__] I was in high school and we were
looking at a film and they were looking
at the the degradation of homelessness
and disparity and I said wow man those
people are really [__] up I'll never
end up like that and about two years ago
I was on one of the back streets here in
on skid roll and um it dawned on me what
I
said and I said I'll be
down I became one of those
people